hey guys and a very warm welcome to
simply learn's youtube channel today
we'll be taking you through an in-depth
tutorial on php in this tutorial we'll
cover all the basics of one of the most
popular server-side scripting languages
that is php
according to researchers around 80
percent of the total websites present
out there use php in one way or another
so it's possible that if you are going
through 100 websites in a week then 80
of them are using php
php stands for hypertext preprocessor
and is an open source server side
scripting language mainly used to create
the back end of dynamic websites and web
applications
this tutorial will let you understand
everything you need to know about php
before that let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to a youtube channel
and followed by form handling in php
once we are done with the basics of php
we'll learn how to link a mysql database
to an html document with the help of php
after that we'll create a website with
the help of php we'll use html css
bootstrap mysql and php to create a
website following that will take you
through the roadmap to becoming a php
developer and will end this video with
some frequently asked php interview
questions so i'm sure that you guys are
excited to dive deep into it so let's
start this video with what is php
now before moving on to programming
concepts let us first see what is php
and some of the reasons why it is useful
now php stands for hypertext
preprocessor which is a recursive
acronym but was originally known as
personal homepage
php is an open source server-side
scripting language that is embedded into
html and used for web development
now two main terms for focus here are
open source and server-side scripting
now open source is a term for technology
that is freely available to everyone
while server-side scripting means that
the entire php script is processed on
the server side while the user just
enjoys the result
now let's move on and see why is php
useful
because websites developed in php
functions faster
with php you can create dynamic web
pages
php frameworks provide security
encryption
it is a cost efficient and an easy to
maintain language
and is platform independent that is php
scripts can run on any platform without
the need of any special plugins
so now that we have some understanding
of php and why it's useful let us move
on to its programming concepts
now the first thing that we need to do
is set up the environment for our php
programs
to do that we just need two softwares
one is
visual studio code
now this is where we'll be writing all
of our programs all of our php scripts
you can download the visual studio code
for windows linux and mac
and the second one and a very important
one is
sam
now zam
is a web server solutions package
generally used for creating local web
servers and databases
as you can see it is also available
available for windows linux and mac as
well
now i've already downloaded and
installed both of these servers on my
system
let us see how to make use of them
now what we need to do is to use visual
studio code
what we do is we go to c drive
xampp folder or wherever you have
installed your xampp server we go to
that folder
locate htdocs
and let us now create another folder
and you can name it
anything that you want to based on your
project
since we are discussing the concepts let
us
name it concepts
now right click on it and
here as you can see it shows open with
code
when you click on it
you can see that it opens visual studio
code for you
along with the concepts folder that we
just created now this is where you will
create all your files for your project
and will be writing all your all of your
php scripts
now let's create the first php file from
here
new file
let us name it tutorial
dot php
and
see how a php syntax looks like
so a php syntax begins with an angular
opening bracket question mark
php
and ends with a question mark and a
closing angular bracket
while
the php
script
goes
in between
so this is the very basic syntax of how
php scripts are written
now let us move on and see
how to write a hello world program using
a php script
so
to print something on php
echo is used
now to use echo what you need to do is
just write the string that you want to
print in front of it
and save the program
so hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
let us close it
and
save the file
now
i am going to show you how to use the
sam software in order to run php scripts
go
and open your xampp control panel
and from the control panel you have to
start this first service that is apache
now this is going to start a local web
server on your system
now open your browser
go to a new tab and type localhost
followed by the name of the folder that
we just created into htdocs that was
concepts
and hit enter
here you can see the file that we just
created tutorial.php
and when you click on it
you can see your first program visible
here hello and welcome to simply learn
now suppose you have a program that
needs to print this exact same string
again and again throughout the program
so
what are you going to do
type the entire echo statement
through your code
or make it simpler
now to make it simpler what we need to
do is we need to go back to our code
and discuss the concept of
variables
now to create a variable
what we need to do is we need to
use this dollar sign
followed by the name of the variable you
can name it anything you want so let us
name it str
and type
hello
and
welcome to
simply learn
so
this is a first variable now this
variable str stores this string value
also you can create different variables
for different purposes such as if you
want to store a number suppose
so
you can store number five
and suppose you want to store a floating
variable
and that would be float
and a floating variable is a number of
decimal points so 7.6
so now we have three variables in a
program
now one thing to notice if you're coming
from a different programming language is
that you don't need to
define the type of variable
in php that is if it is a string number
or a floating variable
now to print this
we can use echo but when you want to
print a variable in echo you need to do
things a little differently so
let us start with h1
heading now to print a variable what you
need to do is you need to use
dot
followed by the name of the variable
that would be
str
and another dot
followed by if you want to type
something
along with the variable
i'm going to copy this code
and paste it
now
let us change the size of the headings
and also change a variable so in the
second line we are going to print num
and in the third
the float that we created
so now we have all of our
variables into our echo
now let us save this program and see
what it does
so as you can see
the variables are printed on your
program and you don't have to write them
again and again you can simply write
name of the variable along with echo and
dot and print it along
now that we know about variables suppose
you want to print the names of different
laptop brands available in the market
now what you're going to do
do you create different variables for
each name that is available for hp a
variable for lenovo variable for a
source
or do you want a single variable to
store store all of the names of the
laptop brands available
now with errors it is possible to store
different information
of the same data type that is
integer string under a
single
variable
the condition is all of the
data that is stored under the variable
should have the same data type
now
let us see how array works
now
array
stores multiple values in a single
variable as we already discussed
now to make an array first what we need
to do is
name a variable
laptop
brand
and
type in
array function
and under that function
we are going to write the names of
different laptop brands that is hp
with separated by commas
lenovo
asus
and
dell
so
suppose these are the four laptop brands
that are available in the market in your
area
now
what you need to do is you need to print
what is
in this
particular
variable that is laptop brand
so
to print it
you need to first create
variable dump now what variable dump
does is
it as you can see here
it
exports the variable that is in its
function
now
we are going to
[Music]
write the variable that we just created
into the variable dump function and it
will just return the data type and value
now suppose you want to print it
so to print it what we need to do is
just add echo in front of it
okay now before moving on to seeing the
result of this program
let us just
make this part of the code
inactive now to do that
we are going to learn a new concept in
between that is comments
so comments are the lines in a code that
are not
executed while
the program is run
so
a single line comment starts with two
slash and anything written in front of
it it does not run along with the code
so
these comments are very useful when
you're writing a
code
to make your code readable and more
understandable by any coder who will
or might later on using the code that
you just created now suppose what we can
do with
comments is
i'm going to write a comment just in
front of it
this is
a string
variable
now
after these
slashes
anything written is not executed when
i'm going to run the program
also now
what do you do if you want to
make this whole part of the code not
functioning
do you add
two slashes in front of everything
or you can use a much simpler method
that is multi multi-line comments to use
multi-line comments what you're going to
do is
your slash
star
this marks the start of the multi-line
code and
to end this use star and slash again and
everything in between does not run when
you're going to run your program
so
we will now see
how this
array works
we will just
reload this page
and as you can see
hp lenovo asus and dell are visible here
also you might notice
this array 4 shows the length of the
array
and this shows
the position where all of these
strings are inside the array that is an
array starts with the 0 position not 1
but zero so the first would be zero
position that is hp
and then one lenovo and subsequently
asus and then
now suppose you just want to print the
second variable in your array what you
need to do is you need to go back to
your code
and
in front of the variable you need to
write the position that you want to
print
under square brackets that is the second
position
in array would be number one
and save the code
go back to the browser
and only the second
array is the second
variable in the array is visible
now suppose instead of a variable you
want to create a value
that you don't want to be changed
throughout your entire program
so
consonants are used for the same purpose
now consonants are very much like
variables except that once they are
defined they cannot be changed or
undefined
so
let us see how consonants work
first
we will
put this code
under a comment
and now start writing a consonant
so to define or create a consonant what
you need to do is
use the
define function
and inside the define function what you
need to do is
you need to
write the name of the
consonant
and
okay first let us write the name of the
consonant
suppose
laptops
followed by
the value
of the
hp
consonant
lenovo
and
asus
and that's it and you close the define
function and there you have defined your
consonant in your php script now this
cannot be changed or undefined
throughout your program
now to print it what you need to do is
type echo followed by the name of the
consonant that you just created so the
name of the consonant is laptops
save the code
go back
and hp lenovo and asus
are visible here
you can also create consonant arrays
along with a normal consonant now to
create a consonant array
you just need to add a square bracket
just a second
let me close this one
separated by
commas
and now we have
the names of the laptop as an
array which
by the way cannot be changed or
undefined through your throughout your
code just like any other consonant
now suppose you want to just print the
name of the third laptop that is
available in the market
now what you need to do is you need to
write the position and the third
position in case of arrays would be
number two
save
and only asus is visible here
so this is how consonants and variables
work in php
now before moving on to the next section
let me give you another situation
now suppose i want you to print
a number only and only if it is greater
than 7
how do you do that
now since it is a condition
conditional statements are used to
perform different actions based on
different conditions
now some of the conditional statements
include in php
are if
if else
if else if else and switch and we're
going to discuss them one by one
no so the first one is if
now
let me create a variable let us name it
there
and
write the value 8.
now the example that we just discussed
if we want to check
if
this variable is greater than 7 and only
and only then print the variable on a
screen
now to do that what we need to do is
type in if
and in the bracket we need to type the
condition that we're going to check that
is if
variable
greater than
7
now
use curly brackets
and inside the curly bracket
write the code that you want to execute
only and only if the condition in of
this
if is met
so we need to print this variable
so echo
where
and go and save it now go back
and reload and you can see it is printed
here
now let us go back and change the value
of the variable to 5
and save it
go back reload
and as you can see nothing is printed on
the screen since
the condition that we just mentioned
inside if does not meet
now suppose
i tell you that
if the condition does not meet you have
to
print
a string
saying that the condition does not did
not meet
how do you do that to do it what you
need to add after if is
else
and else does not need to have a
condition since as
the english
word suggests it is else
which means the condition of if did not
meet
and inside the else we are going to
write the code
echo
the
condition
did
not
meet
save it
the condition did not meet
now time for another condition
now suppose i want i ask you to check
if a number is
divisible by 2
3 or both
how do you do that
now to do that
first
let us
create a number
six
now
check if
variable
percent
2
is equal to equals to 0 now what this
shows is this
brings out the remainder and if the
remainder is 0 that means it is
divisible by 2.
and we need to add one more condition
here
and and
variable
percent three
equals to equals to zero
and
what this does is it checks if both of
these conditions are true that is
if the number
inside the variable is divisible by both
2 and 3.
we will display
divisible
by
both
now
what we need to do is we need to
check
if it is divisible by 2.
so
else
if
since it is else if we need to add a
condition in it to else if
variable
percent
2
equals to equals to 0
echo
diverse
bill
by
2.
similarly
divisible by
three
another you can add as many else if
statements as you want
and the final else will show
okay
let us go back and save our program
since a variable is 6
it should show divisible by both
and you can see it shows exactly the
same divisible by both
now let us change the value
and see if our program works
so what we are going to do is we are
going to change the value to 4
save a program
and run it again
this by 2
similarly
nine
divided by three
and finally
thirteen
not divided by either two or three
so this is how you can make use of if
else if and else statements
now the next conditional statement is
switch statement
now the switch statement is used to
perform different actions based on
different conditions
so let me again give you a situation so
that you understand better
so suppose
you're playing a game
which has four different levels
and
first level is easy medium hard and
extreme so
you need to print that
now what will you do you can also use if
else if but it's a lot of code
switch statement makes it a lot simpler
and more readable
so
what we need to do is we need to
type in switch
okay first what we need to do is first
we need to create a variable
so a variable
suppose
let us name it level
and
level is three
to create a switch statement you need to
type in switch and
enter the name of the variable that will
be passed into the switch statement to
check for the conditions
level
and it also begins with a curly bracket
and inside
the search statement what you need to do
is you need to type case
that is
the first case would be case
one
followed by
a colon
and the statement that you want to
execute that is
echo
you
are
playing
at
easy
level
and
since you want
your program to stop here itself what
you need to do is you need to type in
break similarly for rest of the levels
i'll just copy this code here
two three and four
and just make the changes
and
similar to if else statements you also
need to add another statement that would
be
default
if any of the conditions are not met in
the switch statement suppose the value
of your variable is 20 which does not
make any sense to the game
then
what you need to do is
you need to
display
a default error message and that would
be
invalid
input
and you also need to
end the switch statement
with
a curly braces
and end the
php program
all right
let us save it
go to a browser
and run you are playing at hard level
i guess you must have understood the
concept let us just one more time
change the value of the variable to 20
save it
go back
invalid input
so this is how the conditional
statements in php work
next what we are going to talk about is
php loops
now suppose you want to run a block of
code or a part of code again and again
and again or in other words in loop
so php has that functionality known as
php loops to do the same task
now there are different types of php
loops available that is while do while
and for loops which we will be
discussing
in this part of the video
now let us start with the while loop now
the while loop
loops through a block of code as long as
the condition that you have entered or
specified in the while loop is true
so
let me just
remove it
now to write a while loop what you need
to do is
type while
followed by the condition
and to write the condition what we need
to first do is let us create a variable
and
will
give it a value of 2.
now the condition which we are going to
write is this is just an example
so
if
or while
the value of variable
is
less than equals to
10
and then we follow along with the curly
braces
and type the code that we want to run
again and again until the value of a
variable becomes 10
or
till the value of a variable is less
than 10.
suppose
number
and then the variable that is
where and that's about it
now what we need to do is we need to
increase the value of the variable else
this code this code will run for an
infinite amount of time and the system
might crash so
to increase the variable in each
iteration what we need to do is we need
to use the plus plus operator
which will increase the value of the
variable by one in each iteration
now we're going to save the code
and run it number two three four five
six 7
and so on
let me just
add
break here and you can see all of the
numbers up until 10
are visible here
and after 10 the loop just stops
so let me explain it again
so
what we are doing is we are writing
while
along with the condition until
then the code is supposed to be run
again and again
so the condition is if the value of the
variable
is less than or equals to 10 since a
value of
value of our variable is 2 the condition
is true so the code inside of this vial
is executed and the code will display
the value of the number
and the
variable value will increase with each
iteration until it becomes greater than
10 and then the loop will exit
now the do while loop is very very
similar to the while one
the only difference being
in case of a do while loop
a
code
this this code will execute at least
once
i'll show you how it works
so
in case of do while
we start with two
curly braces
let us use this same
example
and after the curly braces what we do is
we
write
while along with the condition
that is
equals to 10.
let me just
okay
now let me tell you what do we need low
value suppose
the value of a variable
is
11. now since the condition
does not meet
in case of the while loop it will not
even run once now suppose you want to
display the current value of the
variables whether or not if it meets a
condition at least once
so
in case of do while
it will first go into this do loop
run the code and then after the do loop
is complete this part of the code is
complete it will go on to the while part
and check the condition
now if the condition does not meet the
loop will end here and if it meets it
will continue until the condition does
not meet the while part
so it will run at least once
now
save this and go back to a browser
and reload this program and as you can
see number 11
is visible here
so
do while is helpful
in some cases which you'll realize as
long as
you start coding more and more
now next up is follow
now for loop is used when
we already know how many times you want
the loop to run
so for loop is used when you want to run
a piece of code a specific number of
times
now let me show you how it works
now the for loop is written in three
parts here we don't need to define a
variable beforehand
the first part of the for loop is
defining the value of the variable so
variable
is equals to let us
value it at one
now we want to make it
run till suppose 6 values
so what we need to do is
we need to
write the
condition in the second part of the for
loop
a variable less than equals to 6
and in the third part will be the
incremental part so as you can notice in
while and do while we put the
incremental part inside the block of the
code here the incremental part is inside
the for function itself
variable plus plus
and then we start with the curly braces
and we write the
code similar to
i'll just
copy it from here
and now let us
just save it and print to show you
how it works
number one two three four five and six
now these loops are a very important
aspect of programming and you all should
try out different problems based on
loops by yourself
now next up in php is php functions
now functions are very very useful and
very important part of programming in
any language
functions are of two types
built-in functions and user-defined
functions
now built-in functions are the functions
that are already present inside the
framework of your programming language
a very popular example of a function
built-in function of php is echo echo is
a function that is already built in php
and is used to print out variables
strings and values
on the screen
now
user defined functions are functions you
create
yourself
to use a code
repeatedly in your program
so i'll explain you with while writing
the code itself
so suppose you want to use this for code
four or five times in your program
so
or even more maybe 10 20 30 40 100 times
in your program if you're writing a very
very large program you want to
print or use this part of the code 100
times in your program what do you do do
you write this entire code or copy paste
this entire code again and again 100
times and make your code
lengthier or do you just want to use
this piece of code
from here
from anywhere new program
now to do that we need to
put this piece of code inside a user
defined function
so how do we do that
we do that by
writing
function
followed by
suppose you want to call
this function
a name
name
and start with curly braces
now this is a user defined function
named name
now inside this name function
is a piece of code
this
for
now how do we reuse it
i'll show you in a second
so
suppose you are
a long way from your code from this code
you don't even know where it is
you want to use this code again after
writing hundreds of lines of code so how
do you do it
you just type the name of the function
that is name
and close it that's about it this is
called calling a function so
it is similar to calling a friend for
help so here you just called your friend
name
to execute this part of the code here
save
and where there are no changes since the
output will be the same
let us make some changes
add another echo
i am
going to
run it
again
later
and
call this function again
save it
and as you can see
once the function is called the output
is printed and i'm going to run it again
later and then again the function is
called and it
uses the same piece of code again and
again and again
see how simple coding can be
when you know what to use when
now we move on to the final part of the
video
that is
creating a form and collecting its
information to display on a screen using
php
so
what i'm going to do is i am going to
create a new file
say
form.html
and start writing
some html code for a form
form
action
now
here what i'm doing is you need to pay
a lot of attention
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
write form dot php now this is the file
that i am going to be creating later on
which will be linked to this html file
which will in turn run the php script on
the html page
on a web browser
we also need to
write the method
that will be post
now let us create
a very simple form that will display the
name
email
and
i think that's about it
name
input type would be
text
second would be
email
input
type
would be
text
name
no this would not be name
this will be email
also this is just for example you can
also put the input type as email
for an email and input type as password
for a password
and let us add one more field
only two fields will not look good so
let's say
blood group
input type
would be
text
name
b
group
and i think our form is complete let us
have a look
now what we are going to do is since we
created a new file we have to
go
to the concepts
folder and look at the new file
form.html click on it and as you can see
it is the basic form that we just
created name email and blood group
now
we need to add one more thing
in our form that is the submit button
which will submit the details of the
form
let us go back
and
save
reload
and here we have a submit button
it does nothing
yet
now
we are going to
create
form dot php file
and write a php script
to collect the form data
let us start
our php script
let me add and
indent it a little bit
so
in this php script what we're going to
do is we are going to create three
variables separately for all the three
values in a form that is
you can name it anything so the first
variable could be
the same as name
now to retrieve the value from from the
form what you need to use is
an array
post
now this
super global
array
is used to retrieve the value from the
form
now in this
post array what you need to enter is the
name
that you just entered for the values in
the fields so
we named it name
second thing second variable would be
for the email
email
you can name it anything else
what you need to
have same is this name
with this name
now
third let us change the name the third
was blood group so we'll type in the
complete blood group
use a post
global
variable and here
we will write the name
what we've just given here which would
be
b group
and now what we need to do is we need to
display
this information that we just retrieved
from the form on our page so to display
it
echo
information display
foreign
let us start with
and
copy this code instead of writing it
again and again
[Music]
email
blood group
and go
save it and enter the details in her
form
mac email address would be mac at the
rate simply learn dot
com
and blood group would be positive
which we all should be and let us click
on submit
information display as you can see name
email and blood group is displayed
so
let me just add
save it
go back
and
the information displayed a little
neatly now so you get the point
we use post method to
retrieve the information from our forms
we also can use get method but it is not
secure in case of get method all the
information is also displayed in the url
section of the web page
hence it is not usually recommended in
case of secure transactions specially
how to link mysql database to your html
code with the help of php
now to do that we will build a simple
registration form whose data will be
uploaded to the mysql database
and in this tutorial you will learn how
to create that database how to link it
to your web page and also how to delete
the tables or entries from the database
also guys for this tutorial we'll be
working on zam and visual studio code
now let's get started
so first we'll open the c drive zap
folder htdocs and let us create a
folder let's name it
tutorial
and open the visual studio code and
start writing the code for a
registration page
let's create a file
and name it index.php
so
them
let's give the title as registration
form
and close the head
now let's give
some heading to a registration page
now to make it a little more interesting
let us suppose the registration page is
for a blood donation camp
so
we will
name our heading as the blood donation
camp
and close it
now let's give some
background color
to the page
now to give some background color we
need to first know the code for it
let's search for color codes
well i like the saffron one
let's copy the code
paste it here
[Music]
a heading for the
page registration form
now as you can notice i
wrote this heading as h1 and this one
has h2 since this will be a little
smaller from the first one
let's close the div
and write a form
now
in this action part
write
connect.php and this is the file which
will be creating later in order to
connect our registration page to the
database
and method
as
post
let's name it user
so the first
entry would be
name
input type
would be
text
and we have to give
every entry a name
in order to use it in the php code to
connect to a database
let's give this name
name
now what i did here is i put the
required keyword here which would make
it compulsory in to
fill this
section of the form
in order to continue
i'm giving these brake lines to
not make the form
clumsy
email so
naturally this would be the label for
email
and let me skip ahead with this section
so i have written the code
for the different fields that we are
going to have in a registration page
so the first one was name second email
third would be the phone number and
fourth obviously the blood group
of the person registering
as you can notice i have given necessary
type for different fields so for email
i've given the type as email
for blood group text and phone as text
in case someone wants to enter the
entire phone number with the country
code
so
now let us
create an input button
that would be submit
and name
let us keep it submit
id would be
submit
let's close our form
and close the
web page too
now let's save it and check
if it's working correctly
now let's open the browser
before that
first we need to open the sam control
panel and
start our apache server and mysql server
and now let us go to the localhost
type a folder name that is tutorial
and open the form
well this seems to be a problem the
other fields are not visible
let's open a code and see
what did we do wrong
yeah well there's a spelling mistake
here
and since i copy pasted the code
the mistake got copy pasted too
well
let's save it again and check if it's
working correctly
yes perfect
now before moving on to creating our
connect.php file we first need to create
our database itself
so first we need to go to exam control
panel and click on admin now this will
open the php my admin section
where
we will go to new
and create a
database okay let us name our database
as
test1
let us give it five fields and name it
you source
first field would be id
and it would be auto implemented
second we will name it as name
250
email
this will also be backer
third one would be
phone
variable characters since people can
enter the plus sign
to enter the
country codes
and finally we will have our blood group
and let's create our
table here
well as you can see this is the
structure of the table and the table is
created now when you click on browse
it will show you
the data in this table itself
since we haven't entered any data yet it
is blank
now let's
open up
code editor and create a file
connect
dot php
and
let's get started
now here we will have to enter
the name we gave to us submit button
and that would be submit
now we will create a variable to
create a connection and we'll be using
the mysqli
underscore
connect function to do that
[Music]
here we will have to enter the name of
the server since we our server is the
locally hosted server so we will have to
type localhost
now the
type of user that would be root
now the third part is for the password
since we don't have a password for our
database it would be blank
and the fourth would be the name of our
database that is test
one
now we will also check
if connection
is not complete
we will have to display an error
connection failed
now in this if condition we will check
if the entries in the fields
of the registration form
are null or not
we will have to do the same for the
second
second one was
sorry i did not enter the
yeah
email
a third entry
was
phone
and our fourth and final entry would be
the blood group
i think we're done here
[Music]
now we will have to create
variables
to pick data from the
registration fields in a registration
page
now this post
will be picking data
what we'll be entering here
now here we will have to enter
the name
we have given
here
so for the name field we have given the
name as name itself so we'll be writing
it here
let's
copy this code
and make the changes
this would be email
let us also name it email
this would be
phone
this would also be born and
last one would be
blood group
because i am naming the these variables
same as the name i've given because
naming everything differently would just
create confusion in your code
now let us enter these details into our
[Music]
database now insert into sql command
now this
would be
the table name
users
name
email
phone
and
blood group
now we will have to
send the respective values
that would be the
variables that we just created
so first would be
name
second would be email
phone
and
black
now that we have entered the
data into the database let's create a
query
connect it
to the command
and give a message if it's successful or
not
and to successful
else
error
oh good
let us close our php script here
and save the code
and let's see if it's working
so
let's go back to our registration form
and give some
details to it
so
let us name
sam
sam at the rate
mail.com
would be one two three four five six
seven eight and the blood group
can be o positive
well there's some error that we've
experienced
on line four
okay
let's see
yeah we did not close this
okay let's save it
and try again
another on line 12
what do we have here now
okay so this is my sql i not mysql
save
resend the form and entry successful now
the entry is successful you need to go
to your database which i've shown to you
earlier
go to the table users
and
we can see the details present here sam
sam at the rate mail.com the phone
number and the blood group
so now that we know how to create a
database
link our database to a html form
and see the details into the database
entered
we can also delete these details
from this phpmyadmin section itself so
as you can see
to delete this field i just have to
click on this delete button
okay and the field is gone
also if you want to delete this users
go to your database
click on users and click on draw
what it will do is it will drop the
entire table
and if you want to delete your database
itself click on this database
icon
and click on drop the database
now this will remove the entire database
and all the tables associated with it
now let's enter
one more detail set of details to double
check it
let us give it mac
that would be
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
and the blood group would be a
positive and the entry is successful
so to check it we need to go to a
database our table users
and there we have it math mac address
mail.com and the
rest of the details
in this video on php web development we
will learn how to create a website with
the help of php
we'll also be using html css bootstrap
and mysql in this tutorial
so get ready to create your very own
website
now before we get started with the step
by step tutorial let me give you a
glimpse of the website that i'll be
building in this video
so let me just quickly go to my browser
and type in localhost followed by the
name of the folder where i have created
the website
so i'll be making a photo gallery
website
like this
so in case you're a photographer you can
build a similar website in order to
showcase your talent
and if not you can always create your
own personal website for anything you're
passionate about
so without any further delay
let's get right on to a tutorial
so first things first let me show you
the environment that we'll be working on
while creating a website
so we are going to be needing
two softwares that is
visual studio code that we'll be using
as our id the code editor
and the second one would be
xampp
now zamp is a web server solution
package which we generally use in order
to manage our database and create a
local web server
you can download it from these
respective websites
since i've already download downloaded
both of these softwares so
we'll be skipping that
now
let us begin
so
after that you've installed both of the
surface just go to your
c drive
locate xampp folder
and inside the xampp folder look for
htdocs
and inside this htdocs
name a folder you can name it anything
i'll be naming it photo since i'm
creating a website regarding photos
and then right click inside this folder
and click on open the code
so this opens up our visual studio code
and as you can see our photo folder is
visible here
now also one thing that we need to do is
go back to this photo folder right click
and create two new folders first one
would be css so it's considered a good
practice even if you're using a single
just a single css file it is considered
a good practice to create a separate css
folder inside your project folder
also
create another folder
and name it images so this is where
we'll be keeping all the images for the
website
so let us go back to visual studio code
so as you can see both of these folders
are now visible here
now
go on and click on new file
the first file that we are going to
create is index.php
and inside this index.php will be
writing the code for the main page of a
website
so let us start
first
click on an exclamation mark
and as you can see a block of code
already written is
visible here now
so
we just need to add a few things
first
let us
put the title the title would be
of course
go to
gallery
next up
we need to add a few links to our
webpage in order for it to function well
so
the first link
would be
this is a link to
link this page to
bootstrap
you can also easily find it on the
internet
or you can just
type in from here
let me just go to the browser to check
if this link is working
yeah
seems fine to me
now we are going to add another
link to it
now this link
will be for the link for a css file that
will be creating later on
since we will be
putting that css file inside a css
folder
i am going to link it to
style dot css
so that's it
we are done for the first part of a code
now let's
this head section
and
move on to the body section of our web
page
so inside this body section what we
first need is
to add a few scripts
for our page which will be responsible
for the design of our webpage
so
these are the three scripts
that i'll be linking to a webpage you
can just
look and
write them as it is
also keep these three scripts at the end
of your
body so
any code that we'll be writing inside
body will be above these three scripts
now let's
design the web page
so the first thing that we'll be needing
is a navigation bar in a web page so let
us quickly go to the browser
so instead of writing an entire big
block of code
we can just copy it from the internet
so
bootstrap provides
you with many such designs so what we're
going to do is we will type in navbar
bootstrap
and hit enter
so as you can see
just
scroll down and as you can see this is
the navigation bar
which this code will display
also
there are different navigation bars
according to your need
along with the code so you can just
copy any of the one you like i'm going
to be copying this one
click on
copy go back to the code and
just paste it
so now what we have here is our
navigation bar ready
so
let us go to the browser and check
how does our web page look
so after the local host what we're going
to do is we will write the name of the
folder in which we are writing a project
which is photo
well there seems to be some
problem since this nav bar is lacking
the css design let us go back to our
code and see
what went wrong
well yes this css file that we linked
here after css there is not a dot but a
slash
i think it should work fine now
well
the problem still persists
let me go back and recheck
well yeah i've made some spelling error
here
this is bootstrap not botstrap
and let us go back
reload
and yes as you can see our navigation
bar is
well and good
let's go back and make some changes to a
navigation bar the first change that i'm
going to be making is i will
change the color theme of the nav bar
to
dark not mark
yeah
go back
reload
and looks better
now
here
photo gallery
good
also since i'll be using the drop down
menu it is absolutely up to you if you
want to use it or not since i'll be
using it
i'll just change the
name
to
categories
and the three category
will be
the first is
nature photo photographs
the second would be
architecture
and the third
would be travel
so let's go back
refresh categories nature architecture
and travel so this travel looks a little
different from this nature and
architecture
so as you can notice this this line that
is dividing
this section to this section
so let's go back so
that line
comes from this part of the code so
we'll just copy
and paste it here
looks good
now that we're back we don't need
this disabled
and the search bar
so i'll be removing
that
particular part of the quotes
and this form2
go back to the browser refresh
and
all of the parts of the
navigation bar that we don't need are
now have now been removed
also this link
would be
for
about section of the webpage and we will
also add another section or another link
that would redirect us to the contact
part of the web page so to do that to
add another link we will just copy this
code
and paste it
and instead of about
this will be contact
go back
refresh
home contact about categories so this
categories should come before
these two so
what we're going to do is we will just
copy this section of the code
and put it after the drop down menu
right
now go back
refresh
until we copied it instead of
cutting it
so
it's now visible twice
reload
home categories contact and above
looks perfect
so you see now that's the beauty of
building a website you don't have to
write the entire code by yourself
there are codes already written for all
these kinds of stuff this navigation by
the carousel that i'm going to be using
in the website the blocks of photos that
we are going to display
on the web page and a lot of design
templates you can call them have already
been written for you to use them instead
of wasting your time and writing the
entire
long blocks of code
now next up what i'm going to do is i'll
just go back
to our
photo folder
and inside this
images
i'll just
copy the images that have already
downloaded
copy
go
back
images
and paste it here
so now that we have our photos inside
the images folder
let's go back to our code and
write
a
carousel code or just copy it from the
bootstrap
go back to bootstrap
here
look for carousel
so as you can see
this is what a carousel looks like so a
big
photo
in
on the front of your web page as you
already saw when i showed you the
website
these are the different types of
carousels available on the bootstrap
website
you can use any of them
so the first one is just a single photo
second one
is slides of photos
third is slides photos with this marking
and the final one would be all of them
combined with captions so of course
we'll be using the final one
so copy the code for the final
carousel or whichever one you like and
go back to your code
and here
after this navigation bar
paste your character code
click on save
go back
and refresh
so
since we haven't added any images here
there are none visible but you can see
this
carousel has been added to our webpage
so
let's go back and now we are going to
add the images that we just
pasted in this images folder
so in this carousel code
look for
image src so this is the location
of the image that will be displayed
so
type in images that is the name of the
folder from where you will be picking up
the images
for slash and
let me just
go back to this images architecture four
yep
so architecture four
in this alt
type in
architecture and here
is the heading so this is part of the
caption
of the
carousel so
i'll be writing arcade texture
here and i'll make this heading a little
bigger
it's three i think h3 would do
and i don't want to add any more
descriptions
if you do you can write all of that
inside this paragraph
but i won't be so i'll just remove it
from here
i'll do the similar
with
this
so
what we're going to do is we will write
images
slash
and go back
what image i'm going to be adding nature
4 would do
nature
or
type in
nature
similar
to what we did
above
h3
h3
remove this
and now
here the last one would be
travel
h3
h3 and
let me just
type in the
travel 5
travel
pipe
and in this alt
type
travel
and we are good to go
okay let's reload
and voila so our
images are visible here with this
beautiful carousel
and you can forward them and
well
does this not look beautiful to you so
architecture
nature
and travel
but
as you can see we have some problem here
the images are way too big to fit on
this part of the screen
and it's going all the way down
and this part of the carousel is not
visible on the main page when someone
opens the website which absolutely does
not look good
so what we're going to do for it
now to fix this what we're going to do
is we will go back to our code editor
inside the css folder
we will create the file that we linked
at the start of our tutorial style.css
and
here
just write this code
margin
0
adding also 0
and
box sizing
would be border box
so
now
to display the images
on the
just on the main page of our website
what we're going to do is we will
put a dot go back to the
main index.php and from here
copy this
name of the class carousel item
go back to style.css
paste it here carousel item
and type ing
and inside this
we will define the width
and the height of the image so the width
would be 100 percent
and we are going to keep the height at
95
the h so that it does not go beyond the
webpage
let us quickly save it
go back
reload
and yes
it looks great
and
it's also visible on our screen now
now next up what we're going to do is we
will be creating different sections on
this very
webpage
for
the different categories that is nature
architecture and travel
so
go back to the code
under this
carousel code
let us start writing our first section
that would be
section
plus
so
i'll be using
my four and by four
the first
dive
so what we want is we want the text to
be in the center of the page so
the class would be text center
and
the first category is nature
now the next thing that we need to do is
we need to add the images to it so how
do we do that
also we are
not to display a single image
on
on the entire web page what we need is
we need to display small
three blocks of images in a row
so
we
need to create another div
class
and inside the class
we will define the column
for large
systems for the
mid ones
and
for the mobile devices
so
after you've written this class after
you've written this div
the images
doesn't matter the size of the screen
only
three images will be displayed on a
large and middle screen and a single
image will be dis visible when open on a
mobile phone so all in all your website
will be very responsive to all the
devices that you will be using
let's just close it and inside this tip
what we're going to do is
we will link our
image
and
the image
would be
since this is nature
let's use nature one
which image would give we have already
used in the carousel
nature four
so let's skip that
and
put the class as
fluid
and padding
bottom padding would be three
well i think
it's
done
so this is the
first section let's go to our page
refresh
so nature and our first image is also
visible here so what we need is we need
to display two more images in this row
go back
and it's now all copy and paste
just
not this part
this part of code
copy
paste
and paste
so
now
nature 2
and nature 3
go back
refresh
okay there seems to be a problem here
let us figure out why this is happening
okay we forgot to add the
road if
and without the road if the images will
not be displayed in a row
but of this
so
container
fluid
i'm using this
since
just a second
let me paste it here
yeah
and
we will create another div
named row
and
our entire code
will go inside it
and we'll paste it
let's go back and check if it changes
anything
and it does
so our images are displayed perfectly
our first section that is nature for our
categories is complete now
now next what we need to do is
i think you guessed it
we just need to
copy this section
and paste it
twice
since there are two more sections
so after the first section
in the second one would be
for
architecture
the images we need to change
architecture one
architecture 2
and
architecture 3
yeah
refresh
nature architecture
and well nature again because we did not
edit the third part of the code
so the third part of the code
will be for
travel
let us quickly
add the images
so travel 2
travel 4
and i
think we use travel
5 already
so
travel 6
and go back
refresh
and travel images architecture and
nature so
half of our website is already done guys
now
what we need to do is we need to create
two more sections for the contact and
about
so
for the contact part of the web page
we'll be needing a form that we will
then go on and
link to a database that we'll be
creating later on and the about section
will be
responsible to
give
some information regarding the website
regarding the photographer that have
uploaded the images
so
let's go back to our code and
move on to creating another section for
the
contact
so
wait let me just copy only this section
of the code
and of course
we'll be needing a closing tag
this will be
contact
us
and
let's
create another div
class would be
50
and m
auto so
why i'm doing this is because
inside the contact will be creating a
form where there will be columns
and to manage the width and
margin of these columns i am writing the
class for it
inside the step
we will write a form
inside the form the first thing that we
need is action
and the action for the form
will be
about
dot php this is a file that we'll be
creating later on
and the next thing is method
which will be first
let's close this
create another dev
class named
form
group
okay
from group
close it
inside this
i'll write a label
that would be
name
this will be our first column input
type
text of course
let's give it a name so this is very
important
so the name that you're going to write
here
should be
matching should be matching with the
name in the database
and
class from
control
now
just copy this
paste
and
paste
so the second section would be for
email
type will also be
email
name will also be
email
third would be for the number
let us keep the type text in case
someone wants to enter the
sud codes
and let's go back
refresh
check
contact us
the fields are visible now what we need
is a submit button
so after this step
let me
create a button
type
submit
class
so this
will make the button look
green adding some
css
and
the button would be called submit
go back
refresh
submit button is here
now
let us also create a section for the
about part of the page and then we'll
move on to
making our database
so to do that
what we need to do is we'll just copy
this section
for the about
paste it here
close the section
and here
let's
start writing the code
the class
container
fluid so
why are we using this container fluid
class is because sometimes when you
don't use this class
the images or text from your web page
tends to
create
so you can see a scroll bar here
vertically it tends to create another
scroll bar
horizontally which we don't want
so container fluid
close the step
inside it
let me create a class
text
center
it will say the name mac
we just give some space
and
write a paragraph
with a class of course
text
center
otherwise if the text will start from
the extreme left it would look weird
and
close it
let's add some bold
and right
let's see
i am a
passionate
photographer interested
in
working
[Music]
architecture
nature and
travel
photography
next would be
um
[Music]
a
full-time
freelancer
with an
experience of
five
years
well i think this will do
refresh
oh we did not change this we'll just get
right on to it
contact us i'm a passionate photographer
interested in working architecture
nature travel photography
freelancer and all of the things that we
just written about mac
we just need to change this
to
[Music]
about
and i think we're done
yes
so
our web page is almost complete guys
now we need to do some
changes
or add some things so the first thing
that we'll be adding is
an
about.php
file
and inside this about.php file we will
be creating a connection with our
database and fetching the data from it
or sending the data from our form to the
database
so before that
let's go back
to the browser type in localhost
followed by php
my
admin
click enter
but before that
you must
xampp control panel and start the
apache server and mysql server since i
already did i did not show you the steps
so after the my sequel server has been
started you can see this phpmyadmin
panel and from here we can create
databases
so inside this phpmyadmin
click on new
and let us name our database as
graphy
click on create
now what we are going to do is we will
create a table
where the data
will be stored from our form
let us name the table as users number of
columns would be four
the first column would be
course id
which will be auto incremented
the second column would be name
type variable character
250
third is
email
also
variable character 250
and the final was our number
variable character
250
and
click on save
so as you can see the structure of our
table
the table users has been created inside
the database photography
now we need to go back to our code
and write the code php code to connect
our form
to this database
so first variable that i'll be creating
is
gone to connect
the database
since a server is locally hosted the
name of the server would be
localhost
root
that is the default
now if
connection
so this
if condition will check if the
connection is successful or not and if
successful display
connection
successful
next
also
add if the connection is not successful
we should always have an error message
connection
[Music]
failed next what we need to do is we
need to
sqli
select
underscore
db
and inside this
we need to mention the name of our
database which is
graffiti let's just go back and recheck
photography
because the name is
very important if you
mess with the name the entire code goes
away
now
let me create some variables which will
fetch
the data
from the form
in order to send them to the database
so
let's keep the same names
so that we don't
create any confusion
email and of course
number
post so now that we have our variables
we need to run
a
query
so
since we are fetching the data from the
form and inserting it into a table we
need to run a query for insert
into the name of the table that is users
then
name
email
number
followed by the values that
we'll be
giving them
so
notice this is the
name of the
fields that you've given in your table
and
this
these values are these variables that
we've just created
so
inside it
name
second would be
email
and third would be
number
i think the query is done
now
to check if
it works
we will run another query
and i am going to add a header file here
because once you click on submit button
let me just go back
so if you click on submit button here
the page will redirect
to a different page which will just
display connection successful we don't
need that we need to stay on this page
itself so in order to do that
i am writing this header file
with the
location of index.php
enter
and
i think we are done here
now
let's go back
and add some details mac
mac add to it
simply
learn.com
number would be one two three four five
six seven eight nine
zero
click on submit
go back to your database
click on browse
and if the connection would be
successful you can see the
data here and we can
mac
email and number
that's great so
now let's move on to the final section
of the website
so
how do we make this categories
navbar work
well it's pretty simple we just need to
redirect to a section
of a web page whenever clicked a button
so when we click on nature we need
our web page to be redirected to this
section
so
let's just go back to our code
and what we're going to be doing is we
will
create
links
just a second
for every section of our webpage
so let's go back to the first section
that is
nature
and here
right
give it an id
so the id for this section
would be
nature
close the tag
cut
and
paste it here so as you can see
this id
this section of our web page is enclosed
in this id so now with this a tag we can
refer
our this section of the web page
to any button
similarly
we will add
another id here
so the id would be
architecture of course
make sure the spellings are correct
put it after the section
now
go back a id
this would be
travel
okay
just
a second
cut it
paste it here
again
what i'm going to do is instead of
writing it again and again
i'll just copy it from here
paste it
since this is
contact us
let me just put
contact
contact here
and the section
right
and
this will be
of course
about
yes
good now what we need to do is we need
to refer these sections with the
respective ids to the buttons
go back to the navbar code on your
webpage
so here is a navbar code so inside it
you can see after every button there's a
reference you just need to
add the name of your id
do not remove this
and
architecture
travel
contact
and
about
let's go back
refresh
click on categories
okay
what happened here okay no
nature
yep
travel
yep
contact
about so everything works perfectly now
so while we're added let me just okay
let me first show you
rob
probably
start dot com
one two three four five five five five
five
click on submit
so as you can see whenever you click on
submit
it redirects you to the front of the
webpage
i don't want that
yeah the database is working so
just go back
to the about.php
and here we added the header location
index.php so it is redirecting
the
code to the
start of the web page
what we need to do is we need to
redirect it to a particular section that
is contact so just add
contact in front of it
save
go back
scroll down
tony
tony
stark
industries dot com
1 2 3 7 7 7 7
click on submit
and as you can see after you click on
submit the page does not go back to the
starting it just stays here while the
data
has been submitted
to our database
now that we have completed our website a
quick question for you guys
if you were asked to create a website
based on your interest what would the
website be about
let us know in the comment section below
hp stands for hypertext preprocessor it
is one of the most used open source
general purpose scripting languages that
is especially suited for web development
and can be embedded into html
now let's see how the code works
the server executes the php code and
then the client receives a generated
html however if a newcomer wants to
learn an open source scripting language
php is the right choice for rim
moving forward let us see who is a php
developer what job does he have to do
a php developer is a professional who
develops applications programs and
websites using the dynamic scripting
language called php
however the job isn't as easy as it
sounds
moving forward let us have a look at the
roles and responsibilities of a php
developer
first he should be able to create test
and deploy new innovative website
applications in a timely and efficient
manner while concurrently working with
other professionals in order to meet
data acquisition requirements
next find out and correct compatibility
issues involving css html and scripting
often between a series of different
platforms and browsers
after this let's talk about the website
performance
remember to check the website
performance on all sorts of browsers
like mobile notebook tablet and solve
the issues identified by customer
feedback
once the website performance is done
ensure you analyze research and explore
various architectural considerations
relating to the system design process
including web usability the website's
performance and database design
explore and assess different
alternatives for implementing new
application features
so far we discussed the technical roles
now let's talk about team productivity a
php developer should interact and work
alongside other development teams and
company management to solve conflicts
establish priorities select the best
solutions or develop criteria for new
content
he must also develop plans for keeping
the website updated and current at all
times recommend improvements for
performance create and fine-tune style
guidelines for the website's content and
choose the most effective design tools
programming languages and applications
a primary responsibility of a php
developer in team collaboration is to
provide detailed descriptions of website
specifications such as product features
budget programming languages
communication protocols functionalities
structure and deadlines to the other
teams
you should also be able to keep up with
the latest programming practices and web
technologies via reading continuing
education opportunities and
participating in relevant professional
workshops groups and conferences
however these responsibilities may
differ from business to business a small
company may hire a php developer to
handle anything programming related
while a large organization may have a
full it programming department
moving on to the next topic let's see
what are the suitable web development
tools used by php developers
web development tools allow web
developers to test and debug code and
work with a number of web technologies
handled by web browsers
they can be in the form of add-ons or as
a built-in feature inside the web
browser itself
many popular web browsers today such as
google chrome microsoft edge and opera
come with their own set of add-ons and
additional features
in order to keep up with the rising
expectations of web browsers web
developers need to continually enhance
their skill set with better and more
versatile web development tools
some of the most popular web development
tools are typescript codekit webstorm
creativetim and angularjs
now comes the important topic
that is skills required to become a php
developer
for a good php developer he or she must
be able to draw from a robust set of
appropriate skills here's a list of the
most needed expertise and talents
first is to have advanced knowledge of
ajax jquery and mysql then if you're
going to be a full stack developer you
need to know javascript css and html
apart from that other skills like
understanding of apis unix linux and mvc
framework architecture is required
additionally it is also important to
have an understanding of kph and php
unit web framework
as everyone knows cake ph is an open
source web framework and php unit a unit
testing framework
similarly having knowledge of photoshop
tools would be an advantage
on the other hand some of the soft
skills required for becoming a php web
developer is good communication skills
and knack for problem solving and the
ability to think critically moving on to
the salary of a php developer
php developer jobs pay well and offer
great opportunities for growth from
glassdoor reports we found a php
developer's salary to be an average of
seventy seven thousand two hundred and
eighteen dollars annually while a php
developer in india earns an average
salary of two lakh sixty four lakhs 64
043 rupees per year according to pay
scale
also in one of the articles glasto has
confirmed that junior php developers who
are less experienced can earn up to 74
000 annually while a senior php
developer can earn close to 114 000
annually
bear in mind that these salaries can be
higher or lower depending on the
company's size location local demand etc
now people who want to start their
career in php must be curious to know
what could be the demand of the
scripting language in the future
according to tax there were over 5
million php developers worldwide in 2013
a figure which rose to 5 million 500 000
by september 2018.
for comparison it should be noted that
the number of software developers
worldwide regardless of software
development language knowledge was 23
million in 2018 and is expected to hit
26 million 400 000 by the end of 2019
and 27 million 70 000 by the end of 2023
these stats are enough to understand
that php developers have a good career
in the future too if you are a newcomer
or somebody who wants to become a pro
and php i would suggest you take up our
simply learn certification the complete
web development certification course
here you will master full stack web
development in an all-inclusive training
program that includes a complete
introduction to html css javascript
jquery mysql python django and of course
php
now the most basic question
is what is php
so php stands for hypertext preprocessor
it is a server-side scripting language
that is embedded into html and is
generally used for dynamic web
development
is also a very compatible language that
is it also works efficiently with almost
20 different databases such as mysql
post resequal etc
next question what is a session in php
now sessions in php are used to store
data for users under a unique id which
can be then used across multiple web
pages of a website
next what is peer in php
now peer
stands for php extension and application
repository
it is a framework and repository for the
reusable components focus on reusable
components of php containing code
snippets and libraries
next
is php considered a case sensitive
language so this is a very often asked
questions in interviews
so php is partially case sensitive since
variables in php are case sensitive
while functions and user defined
functions are not
next
name
different types of data types in php
so different data types in php include
integer float
string
boolean
array object
null and finally resource so there are
total eight different data types that
exist in php next question
how is echo different from print
now echo it can output multiple strings
at a time while in case of print it can
output only a single string
now echo does not have a return value
while print always returns one
that is the reason that is echo is
faster because it does not have to
return a value while it is print is
slower in comparison to echo because it
always returns a value now as you can
see
both of these commands echo and print
are used in the exact same way
next
what are the rules for naming a variable
now there are certain rules which you
have to follow or certain
good coding practices which you have to
follow while naming a variable in your
php code so variable name must always
begin with underscore or a letter so it
cannot begin with a number or a special
character for that matter next variable
names can include numbers but not
special characters so suppose you want
to name your variable number one two
three so you can use this variable but
you cannot use number at the rate one
two three since special characters are
not included
next a variable in php is declared using
this dollar sign followed by the
variable name
now as you can see this is how we
declare a variable dollar my underscore
variable you can also put a number in
between or at the end while naming a
variable just not at the start
next
name some popular php frameworks so some
of the popular php frameworks include
symphony codeigniter cake php and
laravel
moving on
how to check if a defined variable is
null or not so is a thank function is
used to check if the defined variable
has any value or not so to use this
suppose you have this block of code in
front of you so
suppose you want to check if this x
variable that you've defined is null or
not so what you do is you put the is it
function inside the if condition and it
will return true if it's not null
while it will return false
if it is a null value since it is not
null it returns true and we can
display echo as variable x is not null
while in the case of variable y it is a
null value sin so
the if condition will be false and it
will not display anything
next
how are objects in php passed so objects
in php are always passed by value not by
reference
next question
how to display output directly to the
browser now
in cases you want to display your output
directly onto the browser while
running a piece of code you can use it
use
these special tags
to display an output directly to the
browser now as you may notice
these tags does not contain the php
written you can use them directly and
replace php with an equal to sign
followed by what you want to display and
end it with a question mark and a
closing bracket
moving on
what is defined function used for in php
now define is used to declare a constant
in php
also in contrast to the variables
there's no need for a dollar sign before
declaring a constant since the value of
a constant does not change
now this is how you can use the defined
function to declare a constant suppose
you want to declare the value of pi
as 3.14 throughout your php code and
which cannot be changed so we can use
define for that
next question is related to this
question since
what is constant functioning used for in
php then so constant function returns
the value of a constant it is not used
to define a constant but it returns the
value of a constant so
suppose you define a function constant
using this defined function and you want
to return this value
you can use this constant function for
that
next
is multiple inheritance supported in php
so php only supports single level
inheritance which means a class can be
extended from only one class using the
keyword extended
next
what are the different types of loops in
php so php consists of a while loop
a do while loop a for loop and finally a
for each loop so php consists of total
for loops next question
how to concatenate two strings in php
now
two strings can be easily concatenated
using the dot operator in php now to do
that i'll show you with the help of a
code suppose you want to concatenate or
join these two strings str1 hello guys
and the second string would be and
welcome to simply learn and want to
display these strings together so to do
that you need to use this dot operator
in echo as you can see
this dot operator so first you write
this name of the first string then
followed by the dot operator i've given
this space and then the next odd
operator because this is also going to
considered as a string and then the
third string variable
and this is how you concatenate two
strings
next question what is the use of
function num ar argument now this
function as you can see
is used to return the number of
arguments passed in a function so
suppose you pass a certain number of
arguments in a function and want to know
how many
values or arguments for past
you can use this function for that so
suppose
in this sample code you want to know how
many
arguments were passed in this
sample function so to do that we declare
a variable number of arguments and we
will equal it to the function of number
function number argument
now we will display it
and this sample has passed three
arguments so the output would be three
moving on
what are super global variables in php
now some predefined variables in php are
known as super global variables because
they are always accessible from any
function file or class regardless of the
scope so in all in all they are globally
accessible so suppose you write a piece
of code and you declare a variable
inside it it would be a local variable
and could be accessed only in that part
of the code but in case of super global
variable they are accessible throughout
the entire code
they include
global server request posts get files
enb cookie and session
moving on
how to invoke single line and multi-line
comments
now a single line comment in php can be
made using this hash followed by the
comment or
double slash followed by the comment
while in case of multi-line comments you
can use this hash star and write your
comments in multiple lines and enclose
it with a star and
slash
what i'm going to do now is i am going
to show you
the
use of these comments in actual vs code
now let us take this block of code for
example now suppose you want to add a
com single line comment after this
variable so what you will do is
you can use this double slash
this
is
a
variable
also you can use
slash
this is also a
variable so this is a single line
comment now if you try to write
something else
after this in the next line it will take
it as part of the code not part of the
comment
so what do you do
when you need to write multiple lines of
comment so suppose
you need to write two three lines about
this
line of code what you'll do is you'll
use a slash
star
now write the comment
this is
displaying
simply learn
so this is a three line comment which
you can end simply
by star and a slash
this is how you write single line and
multi-line comments now let's move on to
the next question that is
name some common applications of php so
some of the
most commonly used php applications are
system functions
firm handling so php is very commonly
used to handle the forms that you see on
the web pages
cred tasks now crud tasks are create
read update and delete so when you will
be working with databases this is a very
important part of using databases that
is crud and php is used very commonly in
that next accessing cookies variables
and set keys
and finally data encryption php provides
security through some of its frameworks
which can be used
and is used very commonly throughout a
lot of websites
so now that we have gone through the
beginner level questions that are
frequently asked in php interviews
let us now move on to the advanced level
questions
so
the first question would be how can you
execute a php script from the command
line
now a php script from a command line can
be executed by by opening the command
line
and inside the command line you have to
specify the name of the script or name
of the php file that you want to run
suppose you want to run a php underscore
script.php
so you type in the name
of the php script that you want to run
and that particular php script will be
executed
next
differentiate between a dollar variable
and double dollar variable so
what is the difference between the two
now in case of a single dollar variable
is it is a simple variable that is
simply used to store data
so as we discussed earlier
it is a variable that we defined to
store different data types such as
integer float strings etc
while a double dollar variable is a
reference variable of variable so
this is used to reference already
existing variables
now to use
or to understand how these two work
you can see this particular block of
code here now in this code what you need
to focus on is this is a simple variable
hello which contains the string welcome
to simplylearn and we have defined
another variable as where which contains
a string hello now in this
echo as you can notice what we are doing
is we are using this
also before that you need to notice is
this is
the same string as the name of this
variable so first we are displaying this
variable and then we are referencing
this variable here
so what it is doing is it is referencing
the value to another variable so hello
variable is being referenced so
when you execute this block of php
script what you get the output is hello
since this is the variable hello and
after that what you'll
get is welcome to simply learn since
this variable is a reference to this
variable
next
differentiate between get and post
method
now
get method is used to submit form data
while post method is also used for the
same
feature
so the difference between them is get
method sends data as part of php page
url
sorry web page url while a post method
sends data through http header
in get the data since the data has been
sent through the url it is displayed in
the url of the webpage so it is not
secure
while in case of post method it is a
secure form of data transfer
hence
when developing a website for some
security purposes
usually we prefer post method
next up
how to connect to a database using a php
script
now suppose
if you
are asked this question in an interview
what you need to do is you need to just
write this block of code and explain it
to the interview now suppose we have a
php script
and we want to connect it to a database
what we need to do is we will create
three different
variables that is server name username
and password now
what we're going to do is we will create
another variable con that will be used
to connect it and then we'll use the
mysqli functions which will then
pass these variables to create a
connection so these variable values are
localhost username password these are
the default values now to check if the
connection is connected
what we're going to do is we will
use an if condition
if the con variable
gets and connect error we will display a
error message that is connection field
if not we will display connected
successfully
now as you can see here these names can
be the name of the server that you're
trying to connect i have used localhost
username password for the default values
you can use the name of the database
that you're trying to connect your php
script to
next up what does final class and final
method mean in php
now a final class in php means that the
class cannot be extended
while a final method means that it
cannot be overridden
now as you can see in this block of code
we have used the final keyword for a
class and the final keyword for a
function now suppose
this final class is
being inherited by this child class what
the program will return is an error
because once you use this final keyword
this class cannot be inherited and
similarly suppose this function is
trying to be overridden
by this part of the code
it cannot be because we have used the
final function
next question
differentiate between function
overloading and overriding
now function overloading the same
function is used for different purposes
based on the number of arguments inside
the function while in case of function
overriding
the same name and same argument function
is used in parent and child class
respectively to change the behavior of
parent class method
now let me show you and demonstrate the
difference with an example
so
let us look at this code so suppose you
have a function named show title
which does have contain a single
parameter and displays when called upon
using this parameter displays function1
now if you want to use the same
name of the function for a different
purpose what you can do is you can
increase or change the number of
parameters inside the function that is
it now contains two parameters so when
the same function is called using two
parameters it will function differently
and display function overloading so this
is how function overloading works
next
from this piece of code we can
understand
function overriding suppose you display
a function demo in a base class and you
want to override this demo function
inside the
derived class so what you do is you make
another function with the same name
inside the derived class with some
different properties as you can see it
displays something different
now you create an object for the base
class and when you use this base class
object to call this demo function
you can use the properties of this
function here while if you create
another object that is object 2 for the
derived class and you use this object to
call upon the same demo function you are
overriding this base class demo function
that was inherited instead what it will
use is it will use the properties of the
derived demo function so that is how you
overload or override a class
function in php
now let's move on to the next question
that is differentiate between equal to
equal to and triple equal operator
so a double equal operator is generally
used to check if the value of two
operands are equal or not it is
generally used in case of conditional
statements
while a triple equals to operator
performs a type save comparison which
means that will that it will only return
true if both operands have the same type
and the same value
so
you can understand this more with this
piece of code so suppose
in this case
since they both are equal it will return
true
while in this case they both have the
same
type hence it will return true now
let us
next check this equals to equal so since
they both are one and in php it will
display as true since they are equal
while when you are type checking that is
you are checking if they are equal with
the same type and same value it will
display a false since one is an integer
and the other one is a string value
also if you check two different strings
with the type save it will also display
true
next question
how does exception handling work in php
so when an exception is thrown
code following the statement will not be
executed and php will attempt to find
the first matching catch block so if an
exception is not caught a php fatal
error with will be issued with an
uncaught exception an exception can be
thrown and caught within php
so what we do is we use this try and
catch
method to
try the code and if an error occurs we
can catch
if an exception occurs we can throw it
and the catch function will catch
the exception and if doesn't we do not
include the catch function it will
result in a fatal error
next up
differentiate between require and
include
now require if a required file is not
found it will throw a fatal error and
stop the code execution while in case of
include if an essential file is not
found it will produce a warning and
still execute the remaining scripts so
as you can see both of these include and
require i use in the exact same way with
different functions next up
explain different types of errors in php
now php consists of mainly three errors
notice
warning and a fatal error now notice is
a non-critical error which means that
something minor went wrong during
execution and
a lot of times you just don't pay
attention to it a warning is a critical
error now it is given in condition where
suppose an include function
that we just discussed in the previous
question
then to retrieve a non-existent file so
suppose you use an include function and
the file does not exist it will display
a warning and final is a fatal error so
it is a critical error resulting in
termination of the code so as we discuss
in the try and catch part of the
question if an exception is thrown and
we do not have a catch function for it
it will display a fatal error which will
return in termination of the code
next question
how to call a function by a reference so
ampersand sign is used to call a
function by reference now in case of
reference the actual value is modified
if the value passed inside the function
is also modified while in case of value
the
value of the original
value does not change
so this piece of code here
is
an example of how you can call a
function by reference here as you can
see this ampersand sign will call this
function by reference and any changes
made in the variables here will affect
the original ones next question
create a singleton class in php so how
do we create a singleton class in ph
before that let's have a look at what is
a singleton class now a singleton class
in php is a class that can have only one
object and hence provides only a single
point of access so in generally
generally in class you can create as
many objects as you want and it will in
turn create
different access points into that block
of code so in a singleton class you can
only create a single object hence
singleton so this piece of code as you
can notice is used to create a singleton
class
now in to create a singleton class
you need to have the constructor
function private
now here
as you can see a singleton class is
created using this private construct
and it then checks
if there's only one instance created and
if it is
it functions properly and displays
initialize only once
next question
how to encrypt a password using php so
php
can be used for encryption techniques
now the password underscore hash
function creates a hash password from
the password string using hashing
algorithm so suppose
you create a password string and enter
your password as password at the right
one to three and you put it inside the
password has hash function
so what it will generate is we are
echoing this generated hash
so what it will generate is
this so this is the this is random it
changes every time you generate the
password since it is encrypted and
same when you pass
this password to the database using
hashing algorithm even in the database
the password will not be visible so your
data is secure
next question
mention different sorting functions for
errors in php now let us understand this
question in the vs code so php consists
of different sorting functions which you
can use to sort and give an array
automatically so if you want to sort an
array in ascending order what you need
to do is use this sort function so it
will sort this array in ascending order
now if you want to sort it in descending
order
use our sort that is reverse sort
similarly suppose you want to
sort an array in terms of value in
ascending order so you need to use a
sort function that is this
so in terms of value what in terms of
value means is suppose in a given error
there are keys and values
so it will sort the array based on the
values that is this 22 27 and 37 so the
array will be the same since
the values are already sorted now if you
want to sort the array in according to
key that is this
you can use k sort that is key sort
function that is provided in php so in
case of key sort
what it does is it will sort the array
in key that is the first one would be d
that is duke second m mac and the third
r that is raw
now
if you want to sort
this
array
in descending order in terms of value
you use instead of a sort you use a
reverse sort similarly if you want to
sort an array in terms of key
in descending
you use k instead of k sort k r sort
that is k reverse sort so these are the
different sorting functions that are
inbuilt into php
moving on
what will be the output of the following
code now
if this code is given
let me give you some time and try to
pause this video and think of what will
be the output of the following code
so the output of this code will be 21
comma 21 or 2 1 comma 2 1
how did it happen
but before that if you got it correct
congratulations
but if you want to understand it see
a is a variable that contains the value
1 while a b is a variable that is
getting the value of a variable through
reference
now we make changes in the b variable
with 2
followed by this variable again which is
calling the value of a by reference so
if we make changes here we also make
changes in the value of a now if we
display this since the value of a is
already changed by reference it will
display 2 1 that is the value here and
again since the value of b is already 2
1 it will again display 2 1.
moving on
what are construct function and struct
function in php so a constructor or
construct function is automatically
invoked when a new object of a class is
created and then can be used to
initialize value in class
so when you create a object
an object for a class a constructor
function is automatically invoked
but this can also be so it does not
contain any value when it is invoked but
you can also use this construct function
to initialize some properties to give
some properties to the class
which will act as its default properties
if nothing or
no new properties are given to the class
next is a destruct now a distract is
automatically invoked when an object of
a class is destructed suppose you end
the part of the code of a class you want
you are destroying the object when
you're ending the piece of code a
destruct function is automatically
invoked to clean up the resources
next
is how can php and javascript interact
now php and javascript can not directly
interact with each other since php is a
server-side scripting language while
javascript is a client-side language
but there is a way that these two
wonderful languages can interact with
each other so we can swap variables
since php can produce javascript code to
be implemented by the browser so yes you
can produce javascript code from php
which can then be implemented by a
browser and then it is probable to pass
those precise variables back to php
via a url next question is
explain type hinting in php
now in php type hinting is used to
specify the expected data type that is
array object interface etc for an
argument in a function declaration
now during a function call suppose if
arguments does not match the expected
data type the runtime will display an
error and the pro that is a fatal error
and the program will then terminate now
in this code here what we are doing is
we are type hinting so this is this code
is for string type hinting
and this code is for integer type
hinting now if these
particular set of functions that have
already specified the type they are
expecting does not
receive the same type of variable inside
them
the
program will return in a fatal error and
it will terminate
so
moving on to our final question of this
video write a class so yes this is a an
assignment a kind of assignment for you
guys so what you need to do is you need
to write a class to solve the following
question which i'm going to say so
implement a class named basketball we
all like basketball right so implement a
class name basketball with an attribute
named baskets so you have to create an
attribute name basket and initialize it
to zero as the starting position
and then
create a method name score now when the
score method is invoked the baskets must
increase by 1. so let's see the solution
now so this is how you create a class
that is basketball
now
inside this class what we are going to
do is we are going to initialize the
number of baskets that is this variable
as 0 as the starting position so to do
that what we're going to do is we will
be using construct function as we
discussed to initialize some
default properties for the class
so this construct function is
used to initialize this
basket's
variable to 0. now suppose we do not
call this function score which is
increasing the number of baskets
the default value will be displayed as 0
every time now suppose we invoke this
core function every time a basket is
code
this will increase the number of baskets
by one
so this is pretty simple and this is how
you create a simple class which will
perform
the following question and with that we
come to the end of this tutorial if you
enjoyed watching the video then do give
it a thumbs up comment your doubts below
and our experts will answer them for you
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
keep coding and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you